start with congrats on the movie Thanks
uh what is it like cuz you filmed this
about 17 years ago because of
post-production so what has it been like
waiting to have people see it and then
all of a sudden everyone's being very
positive online um it's never really
happened to me so it's it's a great
feeling it's an absolutely great feeling
to put in hard work and then you know
people not to be ripping it apart before
it comes out because that's always the
hard thing is you know making these
movies and then critics just kill it and
then it never gets see the light of day
or you know so it's it's it's nice that
people are responding well to it one of
the things about this movie is that a
lot of the recent DC films have been I'm
gonna use a term dark a little darker
you know but this is bright and fun and
colorful you sort of talk about that
aspect of the film I think just the way
people observe life you know I'm very
much come from an art form of wabi-sabi
and like what is what's more beautiful
this summer the spring to fall out the
winter I'm a big fan of fall and I'm a
big fan of like dead branches and cold
and it's your perspective on I love dark
I think it's beautiful
you know I mean like so it's just a
matter of like what people really love
this is definitely not dark and vibrant
and I think the world loves this that's
great I think it's just a matter of
people love you know man completely I'm
I actually really dig the fact that this
is an Aquaman movie and you're not
trying to stuff a whole bunch of
characters in it you know it's just your
story yeah I'm saying that if you could
have had a cameo like of a character
just walking in the background who which
other DC character would you would love
to just seemed walk by I mean I would
you know I love flash I'll absolutely
love Azra he's one of my you know he's
like family to me so just to have him on
set but he can't have flash comes strong
to set that just doesn't work
sure um saying that I'm very confident
this movie is gonna get what we call a
sequel I think it's gonna be what we
call a hit so if you could have a
character would it be flash and like the
sequel
I think Wonder will be pretty rad to
yeah flashing wonder what would it be my
first - I don't want to pick one so I'll
pick - um I'm thinking about that I'm
like yes so I believe that every movie
has deleted scenes and I'm curious what
scenes were you sad to see go I haven't
seen the movie yet Oh see you notice
yeah my children were with me when we
made Aquaman so I'm gonna wait it's on
with them so we're gonna watch it the
premiere in LA
what yeah I can't even imagine what
that's gonna be like it's gonna be up at
10:00 and 11:00 the first time my life
they can watch anything I'm in and like
I didn't want them at the Justice League
from here because it was just too it was
just too much this is obviously it'll be
easier with just me there so it'll just
gonna be amazing
you have there's the there's a lot of
cool action set-pieces in this film but
I want to talk specifically about the
fight and on the sub talk a little bit
about filming that sequence and what is
it like filming when you're basically
shirtless the whole time I mean are you
it has to be challenging in terms of
like diet and trying to keep yourself in
shape well no because I got called into
an office and they were watching the
they did like a test and I wasn't
supposed to be sure listen to scene I'm
supposed to have a tank top on because
it we weren't ready to do the shirtless
scene yet
because it takes a long time to you like
it you have to start yourself and I
wasn't ready yet and Peter Safran is
like we really want you to this scene
sure listen I'm like dude I'm not there
yet and so James and they really wanted
that to happen
[ __ ] it so I did good I'm sure it off
and despite cuz I'm at the end of the
day Aquaman's the kind of guy is not
sitting around doing situps anyways you
know I mean like I love a point and he
missed happy hour so I thought it was
appropriate anyway so I would not have
known you were not in shape for it yeah
that's what I have um talk a little bit
about one of the things I also really
dig about this is that the film really
goes for it it's honest to the character
it's honest to the source material and
there's some weird [ __ ] in it and that's
cool how can you sort of talk about that
I try to do my best on being honest to
it but I mean as far as James making a
world that's building sharks happy
or writing or sea dragons and you dig
that that's it's it's cool I think it's
not taking itself too seriously which is
also another fun thing about it right
completely yeah so it's that's probably
fits a little dark aspect over vibrant
and just fun because we're gonna do a
whole different world so I thanks for
the honesty part I'm glad that you dig
it right now completely I mean I'm sure
you'll you'll see it's it's going over
very well
you